let's go straight to brussels now and
listen out for the nato secretary
general just met to address russia's
continued military buildup in and around
ukraine
this was a substantive
discussion on the most serious
security crisis in europe in decades
allies welcome all diplomatic efforts
and there are signs from moscow that
diplomacy
could continue
but so far
we do not see any sign of de-escalation
on the ground
no withdrawals of troops or equipment
this may of course change however what
we see today
is that russia maintains a massive
invasion force ready to attack
with high-end capabilities
from crimea to belarus
this is the biggest concentration of
forces in europe since the cold war
from the start
nato allies have made clear that further
russian aggression against ukraine would
have a high cost
and we have called out russia's actions
plans and disinformation
at the same time nate remains prepared
for dialogue it is not too late for
russia to step back from the brink of
conflict
and choose the path of peace
nato has sent concrete written proposals
to russia
on transparency
risk reduction and arms control
we have yet to receive a response
i reiterate my invitation to russia to
meet again in the nato-russia council
nato will not compromise on core
principles
the right
of each nation to choose its own path
and our ability to protect and defend
all allies
we have already enhanced our deterrence
on defence with more troops
planes and ships
and high redness of the nato response
force
these steps are defensive
nato is not a threat to russia
we do not know what will happen in
ukraine
but the situation has already
demonstrated we face a crisis in
european security
moscow has made it clear that it is
prepared to contest
the fundamental principles that have
underpinned our security for decades
and to do so by using force
i regret to say
that this is the new normal in europe
therefore today
ministers decided to develop options for
further strengthen nato's deterrence and
defence
including to consider establishing new
nato battlegroups in central and eastern
and southeastern europe
and they welcomed
the offer by france to lead such a
battlegroup in romania
our military commanders will now work on
the details and report back within weeks
earlier today we also held a regular
meeting of the
nuclear planning group ministers
considered warring developments across
the globe
including russia's and china's
modernization of the nuclear arsenals
and the continued risk of nuclear
proliferation
allies consulted on how to keep our
nuclear deterrence safe secure and
effective
so nato's deterrence and defense remains
strong
ministers also welcome the progress made
on burden-sharing
with the seventh consecutive year of
increased defence spending by european
allies and canada
this means
270 billion u.s dollars in additional
spending on the fence since 2014
and we welcome that that the large
majority of allies are now allocating at
least 20 percent
of the intense investment to major
equipment research and development
this evening we will discuss nato's next
strategic concept
i'm confident that when leaders meet in
madrid in june
they will reaffirm that europe and north
america must continue to stand strong
together in nato
because nato is the unique
essential and indispensable
transatlantic forum for our defence and
security and with that i'm ready to take
your questions we'll stop the bbc here
thank you very much secretary general
jonathan beal bbc um
you talked about new battle groups um
are those going to happen regardless of
what russia does and can you give us a
time frame of when
we might see forces sent to romania
bulgaria elsewhere
and then also
i think you just said i regret to say
this is the new norm what is the new
york new norm for european security you
say it's in crisis you you're
essentially saying it's going to be in
crisis for a long time
well the new normal is that russia has
demonstrated that it really is willing
to contest some of the fundamental
principles for our security
the right for every nation to choose its
own path and also of course the right to
nato allies to defend and protect each
other they are actually suggested a
legally binding treaty violating those
principles
and they have used force the biggest
concentration of combat force since the
end of the cold war
to uh uh underpin uh and to try to
intimidate
other countries in europe to to in a way
respect or to accept the russian demands
so this is a normal a new normal which
is violating core principles which has
been important for
the security and the stability of europe
for decades
and therefore i regret to to say that
we don't know what will happen but we
know what has already happened
and that is that russia has
demonstrated a will to use force
to try to
coerce other countries and to try to
change some fundamental principles
that are important for our shared
security
and that's the reason why we need to
also
consider more longer-term adjustments
of nato's posture in the east
i will not preempt any final decision
we have asked our military commanders to
provide
advice and
and
provide more details uh on the scale and
the scope
including of
potential new bad groups in the east
in the southeast in in in romania and
the black sea region and also other
potential adjustments are more longer
term presence in the east